muriel à email et présidente de la
fondation france israël muriel aline
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors d'après mahmoud abbas un
des doses de spoutnik vais le vaccin
russe livré en cisjordanie n'ont pas pu
rejoindre la bande de gaza alors qu'en
est-il le personnel médical gazaouis et
île privée en ce moment effectivement de
vaccins je pense qu'il faut d'abord
revoir un petit peu la situation
générale les la campagne de vaccination
en effet ceux des se déroule en israël
il faut que vous sachiez que bien les
palestiniens qui habitent jérusalem qui
sont au nombre de 300 330 milles ont
bien entendu accès à la halle à au
vaccin
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important israël a transféré 2012 mais a
promis cinq mille doses pour les
soignants en cisjordanie il faut savoir
que l'autorité palestinienne n'a pas
demandé à israël des doses de vaccin
l'autorité palestinienne a commandé des
doses pour ce pour toute la population
qui lui permettra de soignies de
vacciner 70 % de sa population sachant
que la population il ya énormément de
jeunes qui ont moins une saison donc il
ne devrait pas être concerné
donc ça c'est une chose qui est fait et
deuxièmement l'autorité palestinienne
attend un certain nombre de vaccins via
le site a mis en place par le ms pour
recevoir caen recevoir des fax le
deuxième point est un point politique à
savoir que depuis les accords d'oslo 93
et 95 la santé est une responsabilité de
l'autorité palestinienne et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça je crois que
l'autorité palestinienne n'avait pas
demandé à israël des vaccins ceci étant
sur le terrain et ça c'est là c'est la
beauté de la médecine il y a une réelle
coopération il y a eu au début de la
pandémie
des formations de médecins de gaza qui
sont venus soit au poste frontière
soit carrément en israël pour être
formés à la prise en charge et au
dépistage des patients qui avec avec au
vide et vous n'êtes sûrement pas vous
n'ignorez sûrement pas que tous les ans
il y environ cent mille palestiniens qui
viennent se faire soigner en israël dans
les hôpitaux
donc ça ce sont des données donc vous
voyez que et encore une fois la médecine
permet des choses extraordinaires parce
que autour de quelqu'un qui est malade
tout s'arrête tout ce qui est
intéressant c'est en effet que la
personne soit soigné donc ça ce sont des
facteurs
moi j'ai énormément confiance dans la
société civile qui permet qui permet des
rapprochements extraordinaire alors
d'après le site i 24 news israël
réclamait la libération de prisonniers
en échange de deux vaccins
c'est cette raison effectivement qui est
invoquée sur place alors c'est ce qu'ils
disent et ce qu'ils aient dit qu'ils
aient discuté je n'ai pas d'information
particulière
il y à israël demanderait et je mets ça
au conditionnel parce que à la fois de
deux de ses ressortissants
un arabe israélien et un israélien
d'origine éthiopienne plus les
dépouilles de deux soldats qui sont
retenues par la masse il faut savoir que
dans la bande de gaza c'est le hamas qui
est qui fait là nous à l'hydre elle
n'est pas dans la bande de gaza alors on
parle d'un blocus mais le blocus il est
à la fois égyptiens et israéliens
je crois qu'il faut remettre les choses
telles qu'elles sont et que pour avancer
dans la discussion il faut aborder des
vraies données j'ai aussi une donnée
importante à vous donner
qui est de dire que si je vous demandais
par exemple si je demandais à vos
téléspectateurs quelle est l'espérance
de vie en cisjordanie
je pense que les chiffres seraient très
différents l'espérance de la réalité
l'espérance de vie en cisjordanie de
l'ordre de 75 ans ce qui est comparable
aux autres pays à ce qui est moins qu
israël est comparable aux autres pays de
la région sinon un peu mieux il y à des
données qui sont des données qu'on
appelle des taudis dur c'est-à-dire
chiffre est reconnu par l'om est ce par
l'unicef ont comme par exemple le taux
de vaccinés s'ils ont le taux de
vaccination en six jours dans les ans
en ami à gaza est très important on peut
se réjouir que plus de 95 % des enfants
sont en tout les tous les vaccins vont
se dire il y a il y a une vraie
coopération il y avait un vrai travail
qui a été fait alors néanmoins il ya
l'eau et ne la jordanie des
organisations humanitaires qui ont
demandé à israël d'étendre sa politique
vaccinale à la population palestinienne
est ce que ces institutions elles
peuvent avoir du poids pour faire pour
faire changer des choses
l'autorité palestinienne et l'ue mais ne
l'a pas demandé voyez ce que je veux
dire
l'autorité palestinienne ne s'est pas
tourné vers israël pour avoir accès à
des vaccins
et si c'était si c'était le cas ça
pourrait selon vos finalement débloqué
un peu la situation
alors je ne sais pas pour le moment
israël n'a pas fini de vacciner alors en
plus il est intéressant de savoir que à
l'intérieur à l'intérieur d'israël
il y a des les populations sont
inégalement vacciner mais pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas accès et parce
qu'elle ne le souhaite pas par exemple
on a plus d'israël de juifs israéliens
vacciner que d'arabes israéliens
vacciner et le gouvernement fait un
effort particulier
justement pour aller vacciner les
populations arabes israéliennes et je
vous donne un exemple qui va vous faire
sourire mais par exemple dans les danses
dans certains villages de galilée
il y a en effet des vaccins qui ne sont
pas utilisés résultat les les juges
rennais rebond dans ces villages et ça a
un effet d'entraînement parce que quand
les gens du village voit que les juifs
israéliens viennent ça leur donne
confiance
ils se disent bon le vaccin est un bon
vaccin donc donc on est en train
d'augmenter
il y à aussi vous savez que 15 15%
environ des médecins en israël sont des
médecins ravise règne et ce sont un
certain nombre s'est mobilisée pour
justement contrer l'effet que news et
poussé la population à avoir avoir le
même taux de couverture vaccinale ce
sont des choses extrêmement importantes
et là aussi il ya une très belle
opération qui a lieu
merci
beaucoup muriel haïm d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl je le
rappelle vous êtes présidente de la
fondation france israël
[Musique]